joining us now on the phone line is one
of my favorite colleagues that I was
blessed to do SportsCenter with it to
see if up close and personal this man do
his work I've known him for over 20
years his love of the sport of baseball
is beyond passionate he's also hosted
World Series postseason all-star game
and game of the week pregame coverage
for no fewer than three networks
he is ESPN senior studio host ko
Keith Oberman how are you kale
been so long it's it's 25 years by the
way I mean that is true I want yeah well
no it's when you get into your sixties
you have a lot more time to sort of keep
track of 1996 is when I first actually
actually Keith I told the story the
other day it's actually even longer than
that because ESPN re-aired the Colorado
Michigan 1994 Kordell Stewart Hail Mary
I was at ESPN to see and then wanted to
turn every television off because as you
know I'm a Michigan graduate but I was I
was in the building Keith because you
were kind enough to offer me an
informational chitchat because of our
mutual acquaintance Eric Sorensen of CBS
Evening News you were in a fantasy
league with Eric and you and you got my
resume tape and you said sure I'll check
I'll chat with him well he was actually
he was my boss at one point so got twice
before and after that but yeah so these
are the sort of exciting things we can
talk about instead of baseball well we
may have time to talk about them instead
of baseball instead of a season I know
where do you think we are right now on
that front Keith I think we're in 1890
1890 was that was the year that baseball
stopped growing as a sport when I was
taking over the country in the in the
19th century and the owners tried to
impose a salary cap
and a salary slot system so that every
player got a grade and each grade got a
salary so they could each salary cap had
five little salary caps inside it was
marbles and the head of the players
Union at that point was a wizard
I think Columbia educated lawyer and the
super star shortstop named John
Montgomery Ward of the New York Giants
and instead of going on strike he
created his own league and all the
players left and went to the players
National League and they actually led in
attendance that year but there was so
much baseball and the the players needed
some financial backing so they had to
get other guys involved in the process
and those guys panicked when they didn't
make money and they sold out but the
National the players National League led
in attendance the National League and
the American Association which were the
incumbent major leagues nearly went out
of business and the the World Series
went to eight games because there was a
tie and the weather was bad and people
were fed up with baseball to the degree
that because it was going to be very
cold and they'd only drawn a hundred
fans to the games of the seventh game in
the World Series they abandoned the
World Series the morning of the 8th game
called it off and it remains a tie in
the record books because people were
just so it was it was a symbol how
frustrated people were with baseball I
think we're back to something like that
because I really think it's actually
worse than we have been talking about
because there's a chance that I think
it's an excellent chess may probability
that the whole ruination of their
business the soiling of their own bed
led by Rob Manfred will have been for no
reason I mean if you think about this
there's still an excellent chance the
NBA the NHL baseball NFL college
football it's an excellent chance that
none of the sports actually get to
Raziel right we're having growth in
encoded in I think 19 states including
some very large ones California is off
the growth list but it still still got a
lot of cases we're talking about some
additional
here in New York because people have
overdone it and just ignored all the
rules and there's a good chance nothing
gets played what will be remembered of
baseball there's no sports this year it
doesn't happen what will be remembered -
baseball will be the Astros scandal and
how the owners tried to take financial
advantage of a pandemic and fired their
Scouts and cut all the minor league
players and did not in a business in
which the franchise's are worth a
combined 55 billion dollars would not
spend the money on any of the people who
ordinarily would work the games and then
this so genius move I'm a proud Cornell
graduate as you are a proud Michigan
graduate you graduated Cornell graduate
Rob Manfred was a year behind me and
we're really proud today the dulcet
tones of Keith Olbermann here on the
Rich Eisen show okay so why why Keith
just the open-ended question of why
would they would would this be happening
why I think well one thing you have to
understand is what whereas everybody
else in the world bought about 31 guys
looks at this and says you really have
managed to find the worst thing you
could do at the worst possible moment
you could do it the baseball owners and
Rob Manfred think they are having a
tremendous success right now because the
to begin with in the best of times with
the best commissioner's the best owners
and the you know sort of necessary peril
that makes it business sharp-edged and
forward-thinking and kind of responsible
under the best of circumstances
baseball's long-term planning is let's
see what they it's Tuesday today okay
let's do the long-term planning meeting
so we can decide what we're doing on
Friday they've never done it never
thought ahead they don't see things the
way everybody else does but Manfred and
I didn't know him in school but I
attended classes in the college that he
went to the industrial and labor
relations school and if they're out of a
hundred student
there were like 10 like me who were in
the AG school or art school or whatever
and went there to get the history
classes about labor relations in this
country fascinating stuff I met a
professor there who I knew up they
passed away a couple of years ago and
they're you know good solid student
going on in that school started about 10
of us and maybe about 88 people who are
hoping day to get involved in labor to
some degree either as a mediator or on
Labor's side and then there were two
guys in the back writing everything down
to figure out how to screw employees and
pay them less and pull their rights back
one at a time over the course of a
century and Manfred has got to be saying
well I know it looks a little bad but
think of the money we're gonna be saving
we're not going to be wasting our money
on a season people aren't going to watch
maybe we won't get to go to and think of
the liability we will not have no player
or fan will sue us if they get Kovac 19
at one of our games we won't have to
abandon it and yeah we'll have to make
good with the Oh with the but we'll put
out a story that we're not going to make
any money on this they think this is
going well
and when they force the strike in 1981
and when they force the strike in 1984
they thought it was going well and when
they thought they were going to force
the players to go out on strike just
before the first anniversary of 9/11
they thought that was going well
there were owners who are kind of
disappointed but they didn't force the
players to be on strike on the first
anniversary of 9/11 because there is
there is a disconnect between humanity
and baseball owners that exceeds
anything else that I've encountered and
this includes all my political
experience that's there are a couple of
people that you could have conversations
with and who have right if they didn't
experience real life in their own lives
I cured Steinbrenner never had a real
wife day in his life but somehow he did
have human empathy and understood that
his business largely consisted of people
liking it it was an amorphous kind of
not defined by the dollar like a sales
are up in Chicago well so what I mean
these guys the rest of them for the most
part
I was looking at an old article I wrote
about Mark McGwire 20 years ago and I
really had forgotten that that in the
90s baseball had had made a point of
noting that they had gotten such a jump
ins in ticket sales in the 90s and was
likely you expanded twice there for more
teams
you better had more people at all the
games you had you know 700 more games
every year and it turned out that the
increase was if you discounted that was
500 people again and they they but that
that was their idea of sales and it
didn't matter that there was a reason
for it that had nothing to do with
people liking it more liking it less
there's just more of it to sell but
there's no understanding of this as a
national heirloom and I think it's you
know it comes from the top
for all the other closeted Bud Selig had
he was able periodically to remind
people that it was a public relations
effort but they were in more than
anything else that sold the product it
wasn't where we provide content for for
people who happen to be at the stadium
no no that's not what you do
you help me you know slant baseball as I
can to get the Brewers back into the
National League but you know these guys
they led by a guy who's who believes
that success in industry is taken away
from employees and given to owners
that's where we wind up and there's kind
of a metaphor for lots of things going
on in our society contained in this
attitude but there is no doubt in my
mind that in the major league baseball
headquarters half a mile from where I
sit right now and in the various
ownership yachts around the country they
think this is great and they are
convinced as they have always been
convinced that the players will buckle
and the fans will forgive and forget and
you know what your people you know
people protesting in every country every
city in the country for three weeks in a
row and given new reason to do so every
other week and pandemic those those
things they don't understand those
things they don't have any meaning they
do not fit into their linear projection
than their slide goals and the you know
they're led
by somebody who does not particularly
like baseball his name is Rob Manfred
and unfortunately is the Commissioner
Keith Oliver in here you really believe
that that that he does not like baseball
like when it all comes down to it I
understand that you bet that that we've
all come across people who are leverage
junkies they have to seek it out if they
don't have it if they have it they must
exact it to this I he does not like
baseball as much as he likes defeating
what he sees as the people who are
opposed to baseball's money-making
agenda so then I guess in the fact I
guess yeah I guess then I guess in the
way you've mentioned mirroring society a
lot here in the same way that kovat 19
has exposed the fault lines in so many
parts of our of our world in our country
and our systems and and families of
feeling pressure in a way because of
kovat 19 that kovat 19 is exposing the
commissioner of baseball as a guardian
of the game that he is not that he that
there is no I I think this was pretty
well known before he was I think before
he was Commissioner I I can't remember
the circumstances for it but I got from
him an Eddie Haskell letter and I don't
mean to take Kenny's name in vain who
passed away who portrayed Eddie Haskell
yes it's just a few weeks ago but I got
an Eddie Haskell like letter from Rob
Manfred some years ago about something
that I reported at MSNBC about Labor and
baseball and I don't remember I mean it
was a three or four page letter and it
was really you know just it just started
with we're all admirers of your work and
your contributions to the game and it
just sort of spiraled through to so
we'll be expecting your correction and
please send us three videotape copies of
it or whatever it was it was just the
damnedest thing I ever read and a 12
year old would see through it and I I
just my entire experience with him was
always of this this was a this was the
proverbial can't see the forest for the
trees kind of guy can only see that the
dollar
and yeah I there's nothing wrong with
making money I'm a capitalist and I have
been overpaid for years
are you still are you still dead money
on the Al Gore cap teeth well I for
associations the name of Al Gore with
several the words you use there but I
was not uncovered uncovered for this and
several additional Whiteside okay to
revise that mr. Gore did not really
understand his business partner just
amazing it's like you you look at them
you go you will go through the entirety
of life not really enjoying anything
that has not been connected directly to
Bunny yes it's it's amazing but yeah
here we are I mean the
the nightmare is the bottom line of this
is that there are people who think that
this is right now is a good thing and I
mean these are the same these are the
descendants of the people who when the
arbitrator sort of illegally came to
them in 1976 and said hey by the way the
whole reserve clause thing that you've
built your millions onto the last 90
years since the 1890 the bottle when you
instituted this thing fully by the way
I'm about to rule that's illegal and
alter players will have the right to get
services go to the highest bidder so
maybe you want to give me I'll give you
a week or two maybe you can cut a deal
with them about this right now you're
fired we're suing and they lost and as I
said on SportsCenter the other day this
is why instead of paying Hank Aaron a
record two hundred and forty thousand
dollars a season they're they're paying
Mike Trout four hundred and thirty
million dollars a year because their
genius businessmen too on top of
everything else and the other thing is
there's no particular reason to believe
that the title Commissioner should apply
in baseball should be used in baseball
because it's just you know boulders
chairman it should be chairman rather
than Commissioner there used to be a
connotation that there were some things
that we're done on the half of the fans
or on behalf of the players or anybody
else connected with the game and that
was several previous commissioners did
that happy travelers
integration when a lot of the owners
didn't want it their men many others who
have done obviously lesser things this
is not a commissioner even in the sense
that Adam Silver is a commissioner and
you know if you're you're Manfred is
there's the Gary Bettman also went to
Cornell Law I mean
Manfred literally is not even the best
Cornell Commissioner in sports want to
point that out again Keith you are the
best thank you this one is as as well
and was enjoyable as I as I had hoped
and then I I knew it would be and it's
great to know Keith you truly truly this
was this was all it was all great and
right now there's a photograph of us
that our production staffs putting up
instead of I guess the b-roll of 1890
baseball that we were we didn't have
ready this is that really four years ago
today that we met in in in that office
and Santa Monica wow I didn't know that
happy anniversary what know when you and
I met and you were taking a meeting I
was taking a meeting in the same spot
lobby in Santa Monica better than mine I
think that was that might have been in
the next be Netflix one that's so weird
I went in yeah I'm still sitting where I
am and you're still see I went no I went
to the Netflix baby you must hear this
you must invoke a minute to this where
the Netflix people one said how would
you like to do news commentaries we can
try to build them out and you could have
news flicks in addition to Netflix and
they asked two critical questions which
would be what about the Italian
subtitles they wanted to know I mean
wouldn't the Italian subtitles caused a
delay in the topicality of the news
commentary and I said why do you have to
have them what we put them on all of
them by the way they have to have them
on English speaking political commentary
well because we have to and the other
one was what would happen if your daily
political commentary did not upload one
day and I thought oh my god what are you
using a Dell laptop the uploads the
video himself well no we don't want to
go there but
when I sell your stock in Netflix is
what I said to my managers your business
uploading moment maybe maybe the anytime
sup house they were just talking about
Gianluca pal Luca could it could have
been that he could well I did yeah we
also talked about the freedom to use
language like that but you people don't
know ISM that is a is a substitute for a
popular compound anglo-saxon expletives
that has been modified to so the
people's like to joke about it by saying
we asked about your mother
so yeah there you go happy 26th as well
same to you that's coming up do you go
all right you take kale you got it's
Keith Olbermann Keith on the one and
only Wow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here